madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur les présidents font des
commissions messieurs leur rapporteur
nous sommes en 1901 Émile Zola publie
son dernier roman travail une œuvre
d'anticipation qui nous plonge dans la
création d'une cité utopique qui devra
faire face au temps où le charbon
s'épuiserait au fond des mines se pose
alors la question de l'alternative pour
assurer dit-il le torrent d'électricité
devenu indispensable à l'existence
c'est alors que sous les traits d'un
inventeur il se lance dans cette quête
qu'il amènera à se tourner vers le ciel
pour s'adresser directement au soleil se
courable Zola écrit de la sorte il y
aura sans cesse là une source de force
illimitée dont on disposerait à sa guise
le soleil apparaît alors pour l'écrivain
comme la seule énergie susceptible
d'émanciper l'humanité encore faut-il la
maîtriser il ajoute des savants étaient
parvenus à imaginer de petits appareils
qui captaient la chaleur solaire et la
transformait en électricité mais par
quantité infime il fallait réaliser le
phénomène en grand
réaliser ce phénomène en grand voilà
bien notre ambition aujourd'hui dans
avec ce projet de loi cette ressource
nous voulons la mettre au coeur de la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
et incontestablement le défi de notre
siècle notre volonté est claire faire de
la France le premier grand pays du monde
à sortir de la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles
c'est un impératif pour protéger notre
environnement renforcer notre
souveraineté et améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat des Français
dans ce combat la France ne réussira pas
seul mais il nous faut commencer par
être irréprochable si nous voulons être
entendus sur la scène internationale
c'est une question de crédibilité la
transition vers une société plus durable
une cité du bonheur dans l'imaginaire de
Zola passe par un triptyque
indispensable et indissociable une
électrification massive des de nos
usages une plus grande sobriété
énergétique une meilleure efficacité
énergétique le récent rapport RTE future
énergétique 2050 montre que nous pouvons
y arriver en développant un mix
énergétique décarboné qui associe
énergie renouvelable et énergie
nucléaire c'est bien là notre ambition
alors que la loi climat résidence a déjà
permis un certain nombre d'avancer
ambitieuses nous voulons aujourd'hui
accélérer pour atteindre nos différents
objectifs sur notamment de la PPE qui
veut que nous ayons doublé notre
capacité de production d'électricité
renouvelable en 2028 ainsi que ceux que
du paquet européen qui fixe une part de
40% d'énergie renouvelable dans la
consommation finale d'énergie de l'Union
européenne en 2030
aujourd'hui dans notre mix énergétique
le solaire représente moins de 3% de
notre production d'électricité nous
sommes clairement en retard mais loin de
rester dans le statu quo nous avons pour
ambition donner un véritable coup
d'accélération de la filière multiplié
par 10 notre puissance photovoltaïque
voici le cap affiché par le Président de
la République dont nous partageons
l'ambition le temps presse aujourd'hui
il faut en moyenne 50 procédures pour
construire un parc solaire alors même
que celui-ci ne décide nécessite que
quelques mois de travaux c'est beaucoup
trop long notre volonté d'aller deux
fois plus vite cela ne veut pas dire
forcer la main mais mieux identifier les
espaces profits au développement des
énergies renouvelables grâce à une
planification territoriale grâce à la
priorité donnée aux espaces légères
urbanisés grâce à un meilleur partage de
la valeur c'est en activant l'ensemble
de ces leviers que nous parviendrons à
favoriser l'acceptabilité des projets
élément indispensables pour accélérer
concrètement nous rendrons possibles
l'installation d'infrastructures de
production d'énergie solaire le long des
autoroutes et grands axes routiers cela
constitue un gisement potentiel non
négligeable de plus de
les voies ferrées leurs abords ont été
ajoutées au texte initial c'est près de
30 000 km d'espaces supplémentaires
rendu disponible nous allons également
rendre obligatoire la création
d'ombrière photovoltaïques sur
l'ensemble des parcs de stationnement
extérieures de plus de 2500 mètres
carrés nous verrons si cette superficie
peut être amenée à évoluer lors de nos
débats mais cela représente déjà entre
90 et 150 millions de mètres carrés en
France
pour terminer nous avons la volonté de
favoriser l'installation de production
d'énergie solaire sur les trois des
bâtiments non-résidentiels nouveaux et
lourdement rénovés en renforçant nos
ambitions issus de la loi climat et
résilience selon certaines estimations
européennes le photovoltaïque en toiture
pourrait fournir près de 25% de la
consommation d'électricité de l'Union
européenne ce qui est davantage que la
part du gaz naturel aujourd'hui
si nous ne couvrons pas du jour au
lendemain l'ensemble des routes des
parkings ou des toitures de France ce
que nous avons voté dans la loi climère
résilience et ce que nous dépoterons
dans le projet de loi énergie nous
renouvelable nous permettront de combler
notre retard pour avancer collectivement
vers un futur plus durable qui n'est
aujourd'hui plus une utopie issue de
l'imagination des Émile Zola je vous
remercie
merci